[Música]
en los mapas es conocido como el bosque
de pemp-pong pero para Los 500.000
visitantes que se aventura en cada año
se llama Roselia
un bosque mítico que aparece primero con
la pluma del poeta inglés Robert Grace
quien en el siglo 12 Menciona por
primera vez el personaje del Rey Arturo
y este bosque llamado
actualmente más que un paseo se volvió
un teatro a cielo abierto
hay que saber que Morgan tiene una
infancia para nada difícil donde
cuentistas tales como christoff hacen
revivir las leyendas de la mesa redonda
empieza a gobernar con Arturo durante 10
años Arturo se casa con la linda
gunidera se cuenta que Morgan el día que
se cruzó con Gulliver el día que
cruzaron miradas las dos empezaron a
detestarse instantáneamente
estos relatos Fabulosos existen desde
hace nueve siglos pero desde los años 80
han retomado fuerza son historias que
siguen hablando de las cosas actuales la
historia de Morgan es una historia sobre
la infidelidad de los hombres son temas
que siguen afectando a la sociedad de
hoy en día también entonces se viene a
buscar algo maravilloso Pero que nos
habla en todo caso
es toda nuestra infancia es fantasía
magia Es cierto que explica muchas cosas
y es la primera vez que vengo a
browsillant me parece genial fabuloso
mágico
solo quienes creen en lo maravilloso
descubren realmente groserían y las
criaturas que lo habitan tales como los
corrigans esos pequeños duendes
bromistas del folklore bretón para
verlos tomar vida hay que dirigirse al
taller de severín pintora e ilustradora
hizo de lo fantástico o su universo y de
roselian sumusa
Bretaña en general es una región de agua
y neblina pues tal vez por eso que lo
maravilloso y lo legendario encontraron
su lugar porque las fronteras se
desdibujan entre el mundo real y el
mundo del sueño permanentemente y tal
vez ellos favorece efectivamente el
gusto por la impresión de que el mundo
no es del todo todo el tiempo lo que
parece ser y que hay cosas que se
esconden y hay dimensiones detrás de lo
que podemos ver
un pequeño lago con aguas oscuras y
lisas anidado en el bosque es justamente
a la orilla del espejo de las hadas en
la entrada del Valle sin regreso que hoy
nos conduce porque Más allá de la
superficie de las aguas hay un relato
había siete hadas que para huir del
mundo masculino se refugiaron bajo la
superficie del Lago y permanecieron
escondidas durante mucho tiempo hasta
que la más joven cruza la mirada de un
hombre se enamora y traiciona a este
juramento de retiro
es un lugar muy bello y es muy simbólico
de la magia que opera aquí en
procediendo un poco como el espejo de
Alicia en el País de las Maravillas El
Paso Entre dos mundos el mundo del sueño
el mundo imaginario el mundo de la
Fantasía bajo la superficie y arriba el
mundo del Bosque y el lago que es de
hecho como la zona fronteriza entre los
dos Entonces es muy propicio para el
sueño y lo imaginario
se extiende sobre 12.000 hectáreas
un bosque más vasto que París
manga fotógrafo lo conoce como nadie
sabe dónde se encuentra cada árbol
extraordinario
[Música]
majestuoso
cada vez que vengo frente a este árbol
es impresionante
libera algo increíble
potencia fuerza es venerable
de este Edén ha tomado miles de fotos
para él la magia del lugar se basa en el
cambio permanente cada temporada
reinventa un paisaje
lo que busco en este bosque son las
luces emociones
lo que lo inspira también son castillos
de cuentos de hadas en medio del Bosque
pertenecen a propietarios privados las
puertas de estas edificaciones no se
abren fácilmente
protegemos muy bien bienes como
castillos piedra o la naturaleza
[Música]
Pero groserían también es un lugar
arqueológico que esconde cientos de
meniles que se volvieron el pretexto de
un taller para los niños
entonces son 10 en la cuerda
acaban de desplazar una tonelada y media
esto quiere decir que cada uno puede
desplazar 150 kilos con Esta técnica
adelante
usa las técnicas de los hombres
prehistóricos para desplazar los mejires
paren porque está retrocediendo
Aquí
no hay opción mágica
vienen mucho Después de los hombres del
Neolítico
los mejillones fueron destrozados hace
6.500 años al final de la prehistoria
al cabo de algunas horas y abandona
roselian tal como se despierta de un
sueño buscando prolongar un poco más
este universo en el que las hadas y los
valientes caballeros aún pueden existir